my background was quite challenging i
grew up on a council estate a single
parent family i was born of a physical
disability
regardless of your background if you
really want to achieve something you can
so my first tip would be look forward
so the challenge i would have when i was
playing was that i'd make a mistake
quite early on and then i'd spend
effectively 60 minutes worrying about
what i'd done in the first 10 or 20
minutes of the game i would dwell quite
a lot and it would affect me to the
point where at half time i get subbed
off
and that's the worst thing but when you
make a mistake just think forward look
forward think about what you're going to
do next that'll take you away from the
the previous era
so my next tip would be find your mantra
when i was born i was born a physical
disability called club foot so it's
basically where one or both your feet
are completely turned all the way in so
it got corrected
my foot still sort of has a slight
angle in when i run over my career i
think i've had many times when i've had
a bit of
i guess self-doubt very negative
thoughts i really needed to work really
hard on that mental side so i came up
with my mantra i'm fit and fast and
athletically strong so it was all about
me being confident in my body before i
played in a big game i would say to
myself that mantra right that's me i'm
going to do it i'm going to show people
how good i am
so my next tip would be to think in ink
by that i mean it's important that
people set goals and when you write it
down it really does focus your mind and
it focuses your behavior and i think
what's good about having a structured
diary is that it allows you to again be
organized it allows you to feel good
about yourself when you've done it
monitoring your progress allows you to
improve
so my final tip would be switching off
i think it's important to recognize
prior to a game or prior to any big
event that you're going to deliver
giving yourself time to think about what
you're about to do early in my career i
used to be very much i wouldn't give
myself that time and space and i'd just
go into a game almost like a headless
chicken because i'd be so excited and
then as a result of that in the first 10
minutes i'll give away a penalty so i'd
always ask people where possible switch
off prior to a big game i like to take
my dogs for a walk i've got two dogs and
that allows me to feel quite comfortable
and confident so when i have to perform
i'm ready to go and i'm not anxious
it was incredibly special to actually
achieve and win that world cup i felt
happy felt ecstatic felt all of those
great emotions but actually the biggest
emotion that came through was relief um
because we spent
12 12 years building up to that point
lost two world cup finals prior to that
if i'd won the workout straight away
with my team
it wouldn't have been that special it
wouldn't have meant anything if we
hadn't had that journey thanks for
watching if you enjoyed that be sure to
check out these videos next and if you
haven't already hit the subscribe button
and click the bell to get a notification
each time we upload a new video